I feel very grateful I've always been
having that much fun like it do and also
I have tons of days where I'm not having
fun you know and I'm very stressed and
anxious and and I came home last night
from just like a wonderful trip and I'm
I'm missing my babies and and I can
slather on the mom guilt and just wear
it like a heavy backpack and look around
a house I just moved into that you know
I finally just got rid of a smell one
place but then this is broken and then
that's broken and there's a like I can
you know but I can look at the world
that way and only look at the things
that can be very frustrating I also
think that I can also see really
wonderful beautiful things so and and
there's also something to be said that
Instagram and social media is just the
Highlight Reel we know that this is just
a highlight reel I'm not someone who
airs my Grievances and that's and that's
just me and I understand that for some
people that that works for them and I
think that that's wonderful you know why
um because I think that I think you're
right no nobody wants to see Debbie
Downer everything sucks life sucks
because we all life can suck for
everyone and so maybe that's why we get
on the Instagram however that being said
like we want to see all the good things
but that's why I think you know not to
shot my own horn but like listening to
podcast where people have real
conversations or your podcast or other
many podcasts out there but um I think
there's a place for for
Instagram um I think you know obviously
it's blown out of proportion and
everybody thinks that everyone lives the
best life and there's this jealousy
thing and I wish I had their life and I
I used to think that way and I have
friends who are huge successful people
way more successful than I am but I
don't want their lives at all because
everyone has their [__] everyone has
their [__] and but I don't think you
want to air that [__] on a platform
where everybody could see it it's okay
to say hey I've been through this blah
blah I can relate that but like you know
but Instagram is that place where you go
and you're like oh my gosh that's funny
that's funny that's hilarious and you
just you know and you just keep clicking
for the next great thing but every once
in a while all those happy things then
you hit something like something really
sad and you're like oh my God that's
tragic and then you just go oh another
thing and now that's funny and you just
it's just this back I don't know what
I'm talking about but anyway but I I
think it's generational too I think like
that our generation wants to see the
happy things you know we were part of
the kind of the the birth of this social
media app where people just you know
first it was Twitter and just updating
like happy quirky funny thoughts and you
know that's funny that that's where it
started and then now it and then
Instagram started with just
photos and um and it's you know turned
into other things I think for like a
younger generation might see it as an
opportunity to feel less alone but then
just parallel to that they could also
see it as an opportunity to feel more
lonely because they don't see themselves
in the videos that are being curated to
them and it's making them feel bad so it
is like you have to pick and choose you
have to it's kind of like like a radio
station like you have to go through the
radio like or or for the children
listening if there are any it's kind of
like your Spotify playlist you got to
like go in and curate your own playlist
that's going to make you feel really
good um
because I mean it gets it can get to the
best of us too I mean I've definitely
gone on social media and and had that
feeling of like oh wow look look what's
happening but I've had that fomo of uh
you know and and fallen into the
comparison pitfalls of that's the worst
comparing is the worst it is and and
that is also I think something that's
really like not to say that there isn't
anyone who in various other Industries
but I would imagine it's pretty
heightened in the film and
television uh anyone who's an actor is
definitely felt that way yeah and it's
really hard to stay in your own lane you
know and like it's like for it's stuck
with me but I always think of it um some
I don't know where I read or saw this
but the idea of like you know if you're
a swimmer and you're swimming in your
lane if you constantly are just looking
over what everyone else is doing and
what their time is you're just slowing
yourself down hang on though see in my
mind I'm like oh [__] I got to pick it
up that guy's beating me I got to get to
that Finish Line before that dude that's
funny no it slows me down it shuts down
my creativity I go well that person's
already doing that so I might as well
it's like Chris Hemsworth he's doing
more squats on Instagram what am I doing
oh my God I gotta I gotta start doing I
like no you don't you don't need to look
you first of all genetically you're just
not Crim Crim hensworth crims crimson
hensworth